joining us now with reaction former
senior adviser president trump stephen
miller
along with the author of they never let
a crisis go to waste fox news
contributor jason chaffetz stephen
miller
start with you this is the danger when
you have a campaign a presidential
candidate that's in the media mob big
tech
candidate protection program uh running
a
silent campaign from their basement
bunker and never answering questions
these questions were barely asked and
when asked never answered
before election day
joe biden was portrayed by the media
during the campaign as a centrist as we
have seen
over the last couple of months he is
governed as a radical socialist
and while he's been in hiding his far
left progressive staff
have systematically advanced the most
extreme agenda we've ever seen
and if they get rid of the filibuster
sean if they abolish
the filibuster they will abolish the
american way of life
they will take over our elections they
will
completely dissolve the southern border
of the united states
they will legally erase the distinction
between biological men
and women they will force you to
subsidize abortions with your own tax
dollars
they will raise taxes through the roof
they will
gut the second amendment and the right
to self-defense and the list goes on and
on and on that is what is at stake
right now the filibuster reconciliation
court packing statehood
jason chavets if they do that well we've
come on harris has already said if they
can't get legislation on guns she would
do it through executive order
we're already seeing they're usurping
the power of that other branch of
government you once worked for the
legislative branch
by just you know stroke of a pen joe
biden things he said he wasn't able to
do as president you got to get the votes
apparently he doesn't think you have to
get the votes anymore
yeah this whole facade that the
democrats put up during the election
saying that they were going to unite the
country
they were going to work across the aisle
they were going to put their hands out
and try to work with republicans
is just absolutely totally hogwash they
know they have this moment in time they
want to blow through the norms of this
country
they want to bypass what the founders
envisioned
you know if you wanted a glide path to
get things done fast
you you would just have a monarchy or
you would have a king
you wouldn't put a house and senate in
there the senate is very conservative in
its nature and that it's
deliberative you take up one issue at a
time you have the debate
but they don't want that because hr one
is the key to this they're going to
change the elections they're going to
federalize elections
put the nancy pelosi's and joe biden's
and kamala harris is in charge
and do everything else that's on that
list including statehood
to fundamentally change how many
senators there are and how many
uh supreme court justice they have it
you cannot overstate how scary this
moment is for this country